in the early 1930s there was a
territorial dispute between Denmark and
Norway over who should have the right to
East Greenland both Denmark and Norway
they made a lot of aerial mapping where
they took pictures from airplanes of the
land and also of the glaciers and for us
this is just really a gold mine because
they are showing a snapshot of the state
of the glaciers prior to the satellite
era right now we are in a period where
temperatures are right rising and we are
seeing that the Glaciers are retreating
very rapidly making the global sea level
rise and we are very interested to
finding out how vulnerable is the ice
sheet to temperature changes and we can
do that by figuring out what has
happened in the past when temperatures
were also changing so we hired a plane
and a photographer so we would take a
picture from the exact same place where
they were flying in the 1930s to make
these then and now
images when you look at the old picture
you can see that the glacier is uh that
is very dirty this is debris from the
movement of the glacier when it scrapes
the mountains and the Bedrock it takes
with it a lot of material if we go uh 80
years forward to 2013 you can see the
glacier has retreated a lot and here you
see not only a huge retreat but we can
also see that with the retreat comes a
lowering of the surface you can see on
the sides of the mountains in the modern
picture there's a line it's almost like
a bath top ring where the glacier used
to be and here the lowering has been
more than 400 m so it's a lot of mass
that has disappeared uh from land and
gone into the ocean to contribute to the
global sea level
rise back then they were flying in open
planes they didn't have any Oxygen or
anything and then they went went up to
about 5,000 m reaching temperatures of
-30° looking at this picture of milk
Glacier in August 1933 and you can just
see the tail of the plane this uh photo
is recorded out the back then if we go
to
2013 uh there's still a lot of ice in
the water but it's actually very hard to
find the glacier front you have to go
all the way back in the picture because
this Glacier has retreated more than 30
km in the meantime this is huge Retreat
uh and among the biggest in all of
Greenland it's not always a straight up
relationship between Rising temperatures
and Retreat and mass loss of the
glaciers it comes in in spurts so to say
it's super complicated to predict and
this is part of the reason we are so
interested in going back in time to find
out if there has been periods where
glaciers were losing mass very
rapidly in the 1930s when uh these Brave
Pilots were flying over Greenland
recording pictures of the glaciers they
had no idea what was about to happen in
the future they were not concerned about
global warming or about rising sea level
but this data that they recorded have
become very important piece in putting
together the history of the glaciers and
to give us more knowledge that can help
us better understand what will happen in
the
[Music]
future